23h21 darry cowl et jean lefebvre joue
la dernière scène de cache-cache au
théâtre fontaine
23h22 départ d'une course contre la
montre
23h42 arrivé à la tête de l'art c'est la
naissance d'un nouveau duo comique reste
encore à un coup de chance mais l'avocat
qu'il a plaidé 3g les trois affaires
chips hibou et de ne pas tarder à
m'arrangerait on ouvre bel le voilà
justement je le connais pas si pour
aller vite et bonbons bonjour m alors
voilà les trois accusés sont pas là par
des photos de tous les droits chez ac
procession où j'ai vu onze littéralement
ça m'arrangerai pour eux mangent les
dadas d'accord mais là c'est bien vous
fait plaisir parce que la vie du début
j'ai pesé ses mots au var où la vache et
17h40 et ma petite amie qui tourne
broche à abobo et me branche accuse
qu'il a créé ce bourg du vdab à la
mariée la marie jeanne marie famille si
le renard de 2-2-2 roald marijuana de
2,2 en faire
c'est en fait un bond un bataillon pas
attention à ces fameux monsieur client
de me demander désolé ce genre de truc
juge je n'ai pas mes deux jambes de
pouvoir pour le pouvoir au profit des
jeunes vous profitez la situation
passion ma petite amie est elle trop
rigide et - kalou a pu tourner au
transit j'ai six mois paris vous vous
proposer notre bon il est vrai de 7 ou
poupaud et le de deux mois avec sursis
mme kah zion a qu à jack
vous n'êtes pas loin du but c'est
bizarre
j'avoue que je dis pas facilement un
cadeau non acquis a dit hé ouais vous
habitez en bas ça je suis bien content
alors ça parce que le monde it in the
second je vais lui dire ça il est très
heureux
je remercie vivement ses alliés doivent
aujourd'hui je parlais tour de france
est passé